-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
The 64th annual Grammy Awards
were held last night,
and featured a pre-recorded
video from Ukrainian president
Volodomyr Zelenskyy.
And I gotta say,
as a 48-year-old man,
I was just happy to see
someone at the Grammys
whose name I knew.
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Oh!
New York Mayor Eric Adams
on Saturday
visited the White House,
and that is the closest
any New York mayor has gotten
to the White House.
[ Laughter ]
-President Biden is set to host
former President Obama
tomorrow at the White House,
and you know Joe is excited.
I'll bet he's turning the house
upside down right now
looking for the other
controller.
[ Laughter ]
The House on Friday passed
a bill to legalize marijuana,
largely along party lines.
Then Don Jr. got excited
because he thought they had
legalized party lines.
[ Laughter ]
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki is reportedly planning
to leave the Biden
administration
in the next several weeks
to host a show on NBC's
streaming platform, Peacock.
Oh, God.
Can I please be there
when you teach Joe
how to download Peacock?
"I need a Roku?
Isn't that one of those
Japanese poems?"
[ Laughter ]
The media company BuzzFeed
over the weekend
shut down its news app.
There were many reasons
for the move,
and number seven will shock you!
[ Laughter ]
The Navy announced on Friday
it will name a ship
after the late Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
And this is cool --
Senor Frog's is naming
their 64-ounce margarita
"The Kavanaugh."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said last week
he believes
Russian President Vladimir Putin
has placed some of his top
advisers under house arrest.
Said Putin's oligarch advisers,
"Oh, no, not house arrest."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Apple is reportedly
set to announce
a new policy to deter thieves
from trying to steal --
excuse me, trying to sell
stolen iPhones.
They're gonna slap
an Android sticker on it.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!